[Music]
brought to you by the every dooll app
start budgeting for free today today's
question comes from Joseph in Ohio
buckle up Dave here we go I'm looking
into financing a boat to use like a
house my I know and understand your
normal rules for buying a house ideally
20% or more down less than 25% of take
on pay 15E fixed and I know and
understand the normal thoughts on buying
a boat as a toy depreciating asset cash
only value no more than 50% of yearly
income when combined with all
depreciating assets this guy really
knows your stuff Dave what I'm wondering
is how out of line or not I would be if
I combined those two into a house boat
if I adjusted the formulas and
compensated for the discrepancies
properly the compensating factors I'm
thinking about are buying something used
with most of the depreciation already
absorbed and financing with a higher
down payment over a much shorter
timeline the boat will have some
depreciation as opposed to a house but
if I compensate with extra savings my
thoughts are that this could work out
similarly as I know you would ask ask
I'm currently 100% debt free and have a
fully funded emergency
fund okay lot to unpack there
emotionally and financially but Joseph
is saying should I buy a houseboat and
can I do it with debt because I'm
treating it like I'm getting a mortgage
on a
home Joseph a boat is a trailer that
floats it goes down in value you could
buy a fully depreciated mobile home and
make the same argument but it would
still be a dumb 10-year
plan I love boats son in Ohio that'll be
cold in the
winter really freaking cold living on
the lake woo I can't imagine I like the
lake too but I'm not living on the lake
in the winter not in a boat oh God you
freeze your butt off um and it's going
down in value and here's the thing 10
years from today where do you end up if
you'll if you'll stretch these things P
out past Friday in your analysis the
answers start to become pretty apparent
when you buy a mobile home you stretch
it out 10 years you take a $70,000
double wide what's it worth in 10 years
you know 20 what's it worth 10 years
after that zip right and and so if you
buy a car what's it worth in 10 years
going down in value you buy a boat
what's it wor well you buy an RV you
could do the same thing I've had people
ask the same question about an RV we
always wanted to retire and travel the
world in an RV that's great pay cash for
the freaking RV it's a toy and don't
call it your house and justify a huge
payment on it because you know what a
two-year-old RV is to appreciate it
heavily hello so I mean they drop they
go down in value so fast that's what
when when a Bago is actually uh Native
American Indian language for
depreciating it's actually what it means
I'm going to have to look that one up I
got a fact check you on that one what it
means means down in value that's what it
means
in the ancient in the ancient tribes I
didn't know you were well versed in the
tribal languages Dave you ceased never
ceased to impress me the things I get
myself into I'm trying to figure out how
to say that in a way that I didn't get
sued but anyway um good luck with
that so this would be similar to an
saying I want to live in an RV I'm going
to take out a mortgage on list I don't
care if you get you a boat honey but pay
cash for it and don't try to say it's
the same thing as a house and please
don't try to say it's the same thing as
a house and a car combined you got boat
fever bad he went to a party on a house
boat last week and now he's figured out
with his calculator how this is a good
idea no it's not honey it it's going
down in value and you're going to end up
in a mess and then you're going to have
to buy a house later on down the road
and you'll be broke well and you'll have
a you know a rusty old I mean you know
an old house boat h e no thank
youh I almost bought one of those one
time CU I really had it bad for a house
I could see you guys just having one you
know at the lake to party on yeah but
I've got a house now but but I mean back
then before we had that we were going to
get a house boat and I looked at this
old nasty I mean you can't say mildew
like old houseboat I mean it's old
houseboat mildew is a imagine the main
on special level of science I'm because
you got a boat and that takes some
maintenance let alone a house regular
boats but I mean my God yeah no no no no
Joseph no I wouldn't do that you don't
find any millionaires that go you know
way I made my first million is I lived
on a boat didn't come up never comes up